hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my agents of shield episode 1
video Ghost Rider is on the show choose
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet ok so a couple
really big things if you didn't know
shield is now legitimate meaning they
can recruit they have assets again they
don't have to walk around in the shadows
that's all because of what happened
during Civil War the sokovia accords
they mentioned that several times
throughout the episode like Coulson and
Mack have been on missions for this past
couple of months just going around
cleaning up inhuman messes so they're
still around but you know number 10 WTF
not that big a deal compared to what
they were in previous seasons so they're
definitely downplaying Inhumans for now
but that doesn't mean that they won't
turn into a much bigger thing later so
that's all in favor of the big tonal
shift of the show as it moves to 10:00
p.m. it's a little more graphic and
pushes into Supernatural territory
number 9 WTF Ghost Rider makes his
appearance so the opening scene was
great I loved the way they used CG is a
TV budget seat like you don't expect it
to be quite as crazy as like Captain
America Civil War which was like a 250
million dollar movie but they did a
really good job so if you don't know who
this version of Ghost Rider is it's
Robby Reyes he is from the comics I
think there's a little bit of confusion
as to like why they didn't do Johnny
Blaze or why they didn't do Danny ketch
so there are a couple reasons why they
decided to go with this version of the
character mostly because people are not
as familiar with him like he debuted
very recently in the comics and even
though I think they're changing his
comic book story just a little bit most
of the really big stuff about his
backstory in the way his arc plays out
with his brother who we met in the
episode I think is going to be true to
that comic book so you can actually read
how he becomes Ghost Rider like he's
already Ghost Rider when we see him in
the first episode which I think was a
good move we'll probably get a couple
flashbacks where he explains how it is
he became bonded with this spirit of
vengeance but there's a big twist with
it that I won't explain here just
because it is kind of spoilery there's a
really cool ending to his arc I hope
they do it on the TV show but all I will
say like you know without getting too
spoilery is that the most important
thing in his
is his family so his family plays very
much into how his story plays out as
ghostwriter so if you really want to you
can go read that comic book story arc
but if they do include Easter eggs for
his comic book story or it looks like
they do moments from it I'll totally
explain it whenever I do videos for
agents of shield but for now he's
something of a wild card they don't know
if he's Friend or Foe so they're just
having a little bit of fun with the way
they introduce him because that's kind
of how Ghost Rider works you know number
eight I don't decide he decides like he
talks about him like he's a completely
separate personality and he kind of is
but what he doesn't explain or what he
doesn't fully understand about his
ghostwriter persona is that he does have
a measure of control it's just that he
sort of like gives himself over to his
dark tendencies when he becomes Ghost
Rider it's true for every person that
has ever become a writer in the comics
that has become a ghost writer they have
this heart of darkness so to speak and
when they're walking around as normal
people their conscience
tells them to suppress the dark voices
inside their head when they become Ghost
Writer they fully give themselves over
to that so it's like oh okay
I'm gonna listen to the dark voices
inside my head so another big part of
ghost writers arc this season is going
to be learning to control the writer
part of himself
number six was just Ghost Rider versus
Daisy that was a little bit of fun like
you get the sense that they're trying to
rein in Daisy's powers they kind of
built her up in previous seasons as this
inhuman with limitless potential
but the you know the way they're
explaining it is is that her abilities
sort of shatter her bones just because
of the way the vibrations work so she
can't use them too much without getting
the special pills that they can only get
at the shield base so that she can heal
herself extra fast so it just creates
more reasons for her to need to go back
like she'll be back on the shield team
eventually but for now like the job of
the first episode is just sort of you
know creating conflicts in the group
creating conflicts outside of the group
so her big conflict this season is in
taking down the watchdog's which is kind
of like the replacement for Hydra in
terms of like big bad organizations so
even though hydras not gone completely
for now on the TV show they've been
neutralized so like other big bads will
surface around the world from different
organizations but for now all the
external threats are like
all the Inhumans that are still popping
up the Coulson has to deal with
Ghost Rider getting thrown into the mix
and then this mystery spirit that might
eventually turn into like my number one
WTF I'm really hoping that that spirit
bonds with someone else and they become
the second spirit of vengeance on the
show I definitely think that this Ghost
Rider will not be the only Ghost Rider
that we see on the TV show now I know a
lot of people like does that mean that
Johnny Blaze is gonna show up no I don't
think that Johnny Blaze is gonna show up
but it all goes back to that robbie
reyes comic book storyline there's like
a big twist with that so if you read
that story you'll understand why I think
another Ghost Rider might pop up in a
place that you don't expect it but for
now that spirit that just floating
around making people see crazy stuff and
turn on each other it's just going to be
this supernatural force like oh my god
this isn't like anything we've seen
before it's really like their
introduction to magic so number 6 WTF
welcome to magic agents of shield so
magic mysticism it's all science that
you haven't explained yet everybody's
seen that first Thor movie so as we move
into Doctor Strange territory in
November with the big movie the Marvel
movies are doing more supernatural
things agents of shield is following
suit so Ghost Rider this mystery spirit
that just got loose is all part of that
like they're just laying groundwork
letting you know that the game has
changed it's not just going to be the
exact same thing with different villains
so number 5 also a game changer life
model decoys so we kind of got the tease
at the end of last season Aida I'm gonna
make you a new body so this is just
following up on that it's not a huge
surprise but I do like the funny twist
the way they played it with Fitz just
like oh my god you are naked what's
going on this isn't a sex robot is it if
you haven't seen Oscar Isaac or Alicia
vikander in ex machina you have to watch
that movie it's an amazing movie where
you know he builds this AI robot but he
goes on and on about how it has female
genitalia and implies that he's having
sex with the robots so it's like this
amazing creation of life like this this
new idea of life but he treats it in a
really shitty way so obviously robot
uprising we've all seen the Terminator
movies so I'm interested to see which
direction they go with the life model
decoys because they make it's like the
they talk about ADA she doesn't have any
consciousness she just mimics human
behavior very clearly they're setting it
up for an ex machina type twist where
she does seem to be aware she seems like
she has her own feelings so you cry when
she ends up dying because what did she
say her job is to stand in harm's way to
be the shield so to speak so that's what
she's gonna do this season she's
probably gonna eat some giant blast get
blown up and everybody's gonna cry
because they care about her at that
point so that's really the tease but it
just depends on whether or not they're
able to pay that off you know can they
make her character so compelling that
you care about her that much then when
she gets blown to smithereens you cry
but what is the big twist with life
model decoys they are copies so you can
make as many as you want so you can kind
of see where they might be headed with
it now they might not do it this way but
you know number four WTF Nick Fury's
life model decoys way way back in the
classic Nick Fury stories he had many
many life model decoys that all looked
like him so you never really knew
whether you were talking to the real
Nick Fury like that was the whole
mystery so I'm also expecting a twist
like that where a character that we love
and we don't think is a life model decoy
ends up dying but then surprise it turns
out to be a life model decoy in the real
person like Fitz or Simmons like Simmons
ends up die like they kind of want you
to not like her in this episode because
she's working with the new director of
shield who I'll talk about in a second
so you know wouldn't it be crazy if she
ends up getting blown up but the twist
is is that it was a life model decoys
Simmons so now that we have life model
decoys just you know be prepared for
them to use them in that way I mean
you're not going to have a life model
decoy without using one for some WTF
comedy eventually but number three is
the new director so if you haven't
watched any of the agents of shield
videos that I've done
they've already explained who the new
director of shield is it's Jason O'Mara
who is the voice of Batman in the DC
animated movies so Batman you know
quote-unquote Batman is the new director
of shield which is just hilarious but
he's going to be a lot of fun
they character that he's playing is
still a secret they haven't revealed his
true name because it's a big deep cut
for the
Captain America Comics he doesn't appear
in this episode we're not going to meet
him till next week but they've only
referred to him as the director but he's
not a bad person he's not secretly a
Hydra agent the way they explain him in
this episode makes him sound kind of
antagonistic like he's kind of hardcore
with security measures so he's going to
be like the hard-ass captain that's
gonna allow Coulson's character to have
a little bit more fun because Coulson
had to be the hard-ass when he was
director of shield so I'll say my number
two now is like the new dynamic between
the group like not you know not really
like a big comic book twist but I just I
like the way all the characters are
working so far like the way they've
written them but I feel like the way
they're creating drama inside the group
it's just going to be more interesting
like yo-yo is just amazing in this
episode just like pushing up on Mack
there is no character in this episode
that is having as much fun as yo-yo so
I'm really excited about her but you
know number one WTF is obviously the
reveal that that Ghost is loose and just
making everybody crazy so the real
question is is who is that going to be
who is that spirit that's on the loose
and whether or not they're ultimately
going to bond with someone else and
create a new spirit of vengeance like a
truly evil spirit of vengeance but let
me know what did you guys think of Ghost
Rider
I thought the effects were great but the
skull looks great I like the twist I
like the way they wrote the characters
it's a vast improvement from last season
to the show
the real the real test is is can they
keep this momentum up through the rest
of the season
so I will be doing videos this season so
no worries about that be sure to
subscribe to get everything and there is
a new round of the Captain America
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so what's going to happen is
is they said some really cool stuff when
they were talking about Ghost Rider in
it involved Mephisto in the Marvel
Universe
now I'm also talking about the movies
too so I'm gonna do like a Marvel phase
for Mephisto Dormammu type video that'll
post later tonight because I think that
once Thanos has his day in the Sun so to
speak with the Infinity Gauntlet the
supernatural villains will become the
big bads of the Marvel Universe like the
door mom moves the Mephisto so again
it-it's going to be awesome and just a
heads up YouTube made some changes so if
you're on iOS or you're on Android
or on desktop there are new cards that I
when I point to at the end of videos
that you can click on now when you're on
mobile now that's not unlike every
single device so if you're on like a
Kindle or you're on like a Windows Phone
the video might get cut off but anytime
I talk about links that I point to those
are always in the description so if the
video gets cut off you can always go
into the description to look for the
links that I'm talking about what you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my last big flash trailer which
is coming back in about two weeks and
you can click here for my last big Luke
Cage trailer which is actually coming
next week thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you